[Music]
here we go
I did trade attention and build
businesses
thank you
I'm a purebred entrepreneur for real for
real for real like documented
I'm incredibly inspired this morning I
have a very clear vision of what this
weekend can mean for people over the
next two three four decades and it's
like fun to be a human that genuinely
actually believes in that kind of
statement and thinks in those kind of
terms the diversity of conversations
that this weekend had it comes from
actually having a diversity of people
I've been really proud of that aspect of
this conference and it's something I
want to continue to Champion not because
it's the right thing to do even though
it's absolutely the right thing to do
because it's the right thing to do for
the people on the receiving end because
they get different thoughts different
ideas it just actually on Merit helps so
many people in this room in so many
different contexts mean so much to me
and so I just want to thank you I hope
you have a great day please do me a
favor most of you don't know each other
and I really hope that as soon as I hang
up here you maybe go and say hello to
just one person that you don't know
because it really really genuinely can
lead to something remarkable for you and
for them so thank you for being here and
thank you so much for being a part of
this
worry brother pleasure of course I gotta
do this real quick that's how we doing
can you give me some like warm memories
of like maybe a New York wrestling fan
what'd you do in the 80s as like going
to shows everything we were too poor to
go to show but I had this move called
the Russian death lock that I used to
throw on my friends Sean can you come
here I'm gonna put the Russian death
lock on you in the 80s like kids like
wrestled each other for real and
everybody had to make up their own move
and I think I came up with a good one it
was called the Russian death old it's
nothing crazy so it was basically like a
full nelson it wasn't anything bad but
what I realized was there was like this
hook within here so I'd go here right
and if I would lock oh there we go I
heard that crack if I would lock what do
you think yeah does it hurt
yeah
so where's the HR department at no
seriously was this is like that's a good
move oh yeah it hurt it was it was great
a lot of people would tap on that move
it's a good hole right it's good right
it worked yeah yeah
the shoulders yeah and uh ego a little
bit
thank you
brother
it looks great
I can't figure it out this paint
is small
[Music]
I don't know if you remember me last
year we talked and I talked about how I
hated my job in an engineer I don't want
to do it anymore and you're like just
get the out stop get the out
okay
I quit my job proud of you and now I got
a new job and I love it it makes me so
funny I don't need to like change
overnight you know of course not your
kid proud of you that's a huge deal to
be able to have the courage to do that
that in itself is something most people
aren't able to get to cheer for yourself
on that Timbo what's up Legend how you
doing great show man thank you for
having me bye guys love you Gary all
right talk to you soon
[Music]
oh this is awesome
it's crazy to see the original
even like the way I'm looking at them
this year versus last year I feel like
it's been 20 years it's going to be like
super emotional to look at you know
[Music]
hey Gary how's it going well
If I Had Gary ears it would stick
perfectly
[Music]
he's playing different
pops is different oh my God thank you
really really bad appreciate it yeah
[Music]
so I know you're focused on that I just
want to say this is the first time I've
ever been at a conference with everyone
was pleasant everyone was happy everyone
was you're willing to interrupt
conversations to engage you and it was
so easy to talk to people you built
something that truly is individual
that means a lot to me and I say thank
you because I do conferences thank you
baby thank you thank you
welcome back to the beacon biker stage
Gary vaynerchuk
love you back bro
what's up brother
[Music]
[Applause]
because
vcon 2023 how we feeling
mecon how did we feel about this year
and so this keynote today
is going to be with you involved by I
actually don't know the videos I asked
the team to go through all the videos
that were submitted and I'm going to
answer q a right now based on the
questions from y'all but let me go into
the keynote let's queue up the first
question you know people struggle with
this fear of how do I express myself how
do I feel good about who I am when I'm
in a social situation what advice do you
have for people to get closer to that
point so that they can really just feel
that confident with themselves I don't
know if you heard
but high school is over
the amount of people that put other
people's opinions of them on a pedestal
is an issue I would die if you valued my
opinion of you over your opinion of
yourself to answer his question directly
the way you get better at anything in
the world is practice
you want to get better at basketball you
practice you want to get better at
singing you practice you want to get
better at DJing you practice you want to
cook better you practice you want to be
a better entrepreneur you practice you
want to get better at having
self-confidence you practice on not
valuing someone else's opinion over your
own opinion of yourself
you practice by putting yourself out
there more
more
the context of this conference is super
powerful and will be no question an
aggressive theme of mine for 2024 is to
push you to say hello to more people
more more because what you're going to
get here as you know is positive
reinforcement you're going to get
reciprocated likely at a high percentage
in a good way
I'm not naive I'm sure that even though
we tried to push this nice movement like
all this that some people weren't
receptive and things are they sure they
might have been dealing with something
they might be introverted themselves but
you get practice the way you get more
confident in yourself is you stop
putting other people's opinions of
yourself in front of yours then they go
to me but Gary what if it's my opinion
of myself that I suck then I remind them
that that was instilled in you if you
think you suck as you sit here today
that you suck I want you to understand
something
that was somebody else's voice putting
that inside of your head
that person
felt sucky about themselves too
[Music]
much
that's Uno Gary in there
all right
[Music]
[Applause]
brother congratulations
[Music]
don't have me sign this you should get
this graded my signature one of ones I
wouldn't get signed get that created
Without Me
Now give me a bomb
[Music]
foreign
midnight Saturday night if nothing too
fancy a lot of Chaos
Nikon appreciate you we did it team did
it we all did it see you next year
foreign